All right, today we're tackling a really
cool idea from our source materials, the
story of the original versus the copy.
We're going to explore the relationship
between essential nutrients our bodies
desperately need and some of the most
common drugs out there. So, get this.
What if some of the most common
medications we reach for, things like
painkillers and blood thinners, what if
they were just man-made copies of
something our bodies are already
designed to use? This is the central
question our sources pose and it really
frames everything we're about to dive
into. Okay, first up, let's start with
stuff that's probably pretty familiar to
all of us. We're talking about common
health issues and the go-to solutions
that you might find in just about any
medicine cabinet, right? So, you've got
things like inflammation and pain or
worries about blood clot risks. Super
common stuff. And the typical solutions
as highlighted in our sources are names
you'll definitely recognize. Aspirin,
Motrin, Couadin, Plavix, Eloquis. You've
heard of them, right? They're household
names for a reason. But how do these
drugs actually get the job done? The
sources we're looking at have a very
specific and honestly kind of surprising
way of explaining how they work. Whoa.
Okay, let's pause on that for a second.
Poisons. That is a very strong word and
it's a direct quote from the source
material. The argument being made here
is that these drugs don't really build
anything up. Instead, they work by
suppressing or blocking or as they put
it, shutting down a part of your body to
get rid of a symptom. It's a really
provocative way to look at it. And this
is where you see the other side of that
coin. This table lays out some of those
familiar drugs right next to their
potential serious side effects. For
things like aspirin and Motrin, you're
looking at risks like GI bleeding or
even an increased chance of heart attack
or stroke. And for the anti-coagulants,
the big worry is of course major
bleeding. So the point being made is
pretty clear. Yes, they manage symptoms,
but that can come with a pretty serious
list of potential costs. Okay, so we've
looked at what our sources are calling
the copy. Now, let's flip the script and
turn our attention to what they call the
original. This is where the whole story
pivots from the pharmacy to the pantry.
And the original all comes down to
something called essential fatty acids
or EFAs for short. And that word
essential, it's not a suggestion. It
means your body has to have them to be
healthy, but it can't make them from
scratch. You've got to get them from
your food. We're talking about things
like omega-3 and omega 6. And here's the
real kicker. Our sources present EFAs as
the actual tools your body uses to
regulate itself. They're the fundamental
building blocks for handling things like
inflammation and keeping your blood
flowing smoothly all on its own the way
it was designed to. So, this brings us
to the main event. This is where we put
the two approaches side by side. Let's
really look at how the nutrient and the
drug stack up when they're trying to
solve the exact same problem. First up,
inflammation. On one side, you've got
EFAs, which the source is called
nature's aspirin. The idea is they give
your body the raw materials it needs to
find balance. But on the other side,
you've got the ensates. They're
presented as just mimicking the effect
by forcefully suppressing the system,
which as we saw, can lead to some
serious problems. It's a really similar
story when you look at blood flow. EFAs
are called nature's blood thinner and
are described as working kindly and
gently. Then you have anti-coagulants
like warerin. And our sources make a
pretty startling point here. That same
core ingredient is also used as rat
poison. The argument is that it doesn't
work with your body. It just overrides
the whole clotting system completely. So
here it is all boiled down. This is the
big aha moment. The core argument from
our sources is support versus override.
The nutrient approach is all about
giving your body the parts it needs to
fix itself. The pharmaceutical approach
is described as blocking a pathway to
get rid of a symptom. It's like one is
giving the mechanic the right tools and
the other is just cutting the wire to
the check engine light. But hold on, the
story doesn't stop there. Because
according to our sources, the benefits
of these original nutrients go way, way
beyond what those copy drugs could ever
do. The scope is just huge. I mean, just
take a look at the brain and nervous
system. EFAs are presented as the
literal raw material for your
neurotransmitters and are critical for
the very structure of your brain cells.
Our sources even point to literature
suggesting they can be as effective as
anti-depressants for supporting mood.
They're key for focus, for awareness,
even for a baby's brain developing in
the womb. Then there's the actual nuts
and bolts of your body. The sources call
EFAs the single most important nutrient
for your skin, helping to hydrate it
from the inside out. But it goes deeper.
They're required for the structure of
every single cell wall. They help patch
up a leaky gut and can even turn on the
genes for building stronger bones. And
it just keeps going. Your hormones, yep,
you need EFAs to produce them. Your
ability to breathe. They're precursors
to little messengers that keep your
airways open. In fact, a deficiency is
directly linked in the sources to
conditions like asthma. You start to get
this picture of a nutrient that is truly
essential for, well, everything. And
that brings us to this final really
critical question our source material
leaves us with. This isn't just about
what pill to take. It's about a
fundamental approach to health. Should
our main focus be on suppressing
symptoms with a copy or should it be on
providing the body with its essential
building blocks, the original? That's a
powerful idea to think about. Thanks for
joining me.